Shh I've snuck into minutephysics studio
to explain how a wing actually works
hang on mmm something doesn't feel right
ah that's better
now everyone knows that a wing generates
lift due to its characteristic shape
since air travels farther over the top
of the wing it must go faster than the
air underneath so that both streams meet
up simultaneously at the trailing edge
and according to Bernoulli's principle
faster flowing air exerts less pressure
than the slower air beneath the wing
this pressure difference creates an
upward force lift job done right nope
this simple explanation taught in many
textbooks and classrooms has obvious
problems like how could a plane fly
upside down some planes like the Wright
brothers had nearly flat wings so
presumably air would travel the same
speed over both sides and there would be
no lift Plus experiments show that air
streams don't meet up at the back of the
wing air over the top goes significantly
faster reaching the trailing edge first
so how does a wing actually generate
lift well the key is the wing must
deflect air downwards this can be
achieved using a symmetric or cambered
airfoil or by increasing the angle of
attack air under the wing is deflected
down and by the co and ax affect air
above the wing is guided along its
surface and down as well since the air
is slowed and deflected down by the wing
it pushes the wing up and back lift and
drag this is in accordance with Newton's
third law of motion but hang on if you
can explain lift only using the
deflection of air and Newton's laws then
the Bernoulli explanation must be
completely wrong well no air over the
top of the wing does go faster than air
beneath creating a pressure difference
that generates lift then this Newtonian
explanation is unnecessary rubbish and
the original explanation was right but
that's not true either the original
explanation incorrectly assumed that air
over and under the wing must reconnect
at the trailing edge and there was no
mention of deflecting air down each
explanation done correctly completely
accounts for the lift generated by a
wing they're just two different ways of
looking at the same thing so next time
someone brings up the standard
misconception you can tell them that
one nation just doesn't fly and if you
like that you've got to check out
minutephysics I have total respect for a
guy who does this every week sincerely a
collection of particles known as Derrick
you
you